[Música]
cuando roberto me pidió que hablara un
poco de la tecnología aplicada al sector
financiero esto fue la primera imagen
que se me vino a la mente es la anterior
era el corno de la bolsa nacional de
valores el 19 de agosto de 1976 hace 42
años cuando se fundó la bolsa de valores
y todas las transacciones se hacían
físicamente y en ese corro ustedes van a
ver en la parte de arriba dos personas
esos eran los anotadores los anotadores
era un trabajo muy importante que tenían
un borrador y una tiza y cada vez que un
corredor de bolsa pujaba borraba el
precio anterior de la pizarra y ponía
con tiza el nuevo precio que se iba a
hacer la transacción
el cuadro físico dejó de existir hace
muchos años fue sustituido por un correo
electrónico que funciona y que operar lo
más bien pero no todo el resto de la
cadena de valor de la bolsa o el sistema
financiero en general fue sustituida de
la misma manera hasta que llegamos al
2018 en que vemos una impedancia
necesidad de reformarlo de
transformarlos necesidad que se da por
los grandes cambios que están ocurriendo
en todo el mundo
cambios a su vez que se generan porque
ha habido en los años anteriores cuatro
inventos fundamentales las computadoras
que se unieron después con el internet
para que se pudieran hablar entre sí las
cámaras digitales que después nos
llevaron a tener videoconferencias y
todo lo que conocemos en el mundo del
vídeo y los mal llamados teléfonos
inteligentes que realmente son una
computadora bastante más poderosa que la
primera pc de ibm que salió en los años
si con cuatro inventos llegamos a donde
estamos hoy en el 2018 con la tecnología
y con las maravillas que no dejamos de
asombrar los a donde iremos a llegar
cuando estas otras tecnologías se
empiecen a dar todos sus frutos vamos a
tener no solamente impresión digital en
la que vamos a imprimir la camiseta sin
pagar impuestos cuando le importamos de
imagen desde la china el imperio vamos
en nuestra casa vamos a tener realidad
aumentada con la cual vamos a tener que
cambiar una llanta y si no sabemos lo
vamos a hacer poniendo nuestro celular y
un vídeo sobre la llanta nos va a
explicar cómo se cambia la llanta vamos
a tener la conjunción de diferentes
tecnologías como la robótica y la
inteligencia artificial que se tienen
orígenes diferentes pero que cuando se
juntan se suman y se convierten en un
invento exponencial vamos a tener podría
hablar de cada una de ellos pero por
ejemplo el ecommerce cojamos un que es
global y se va a juntar con el internet
de las cosas millones de cosas se van a
conectar al internet y se van a hablar
entre sí cuando las cosas empiecen a
hablar si saquemos una caja de leche del
refrigerador el refrigerador le voy a
llamar a 21 y le va a decir que se acabó
la leche en la casa y que nos mande una
nueva caja
la cual va a venir en un dron y nos van
a depositar en la puerta de nuestra casa
y por supuesto está también el block
change que es el fundamento y la madre
de todos los cambios que vamos a ver
ahora en el sistema financiero el broche
en es la tecnología sobre la cual se
basa en la script o monedas y se basa en
los contratos inteligentes y las cámaras
de compensación y todo lo que sabemos
hacia el familiarmente en el dominio
físico en el sistema financiero ahora
bien esas tendencias no terminan ahí
esas tendencias se siguen incrementando
fíjense que para el año 2020 va a haber
50 mil millones de objetos pegados al
internet y vamos a haber subido del 2015
de 2.000 millones de personas de los 7
mil que hay en el mundo a 5 mil millones
de personas usuarios del internet esos 3
mil millones de mentes adicionales los
veamos los comúnmente si no hago nada
más como personas van a estar inventando
cosas si dos mil ya inventaron el güey
selu en el amazon en wikipedia todos los
caps que tenemos en estos aparatos
a dónde iremos a llegar cuando tres mil
millones de personas adicionales sigan
inventando cosas para facilitarnos la
vida y para facilitar el mundo ese
crecimiento se está dando porque hay una
ley de moore que hace que explican que
la tecnología se divide el precio cada
18 meses aproximadamente entre dos a la
mitad y se duplica la capacidad
tecnológica cuesta la mitad y hacemos el
doble con esa tecnología eso va a hacer
que este aparatito en el 2029 tenga la
capacidad de un ser humano va a aumentar
su capacidad cien veces y va a venir
aquí a darles charlas este iba a ser el
que nos sustituya a todos nosotros buena
noticia en nuestros trabajos mientras
nosotros vamos a estar haciendo alguna
otra cosa porque el celular es el que va
a dirigir las empresas y las
organizaciones esta tasa de cambio tan
acelerada sólo la podemos entender si
entendemos la diferencia entre el cambio
lineal y el cambio exponencial el cambio
lineal es cuando avanzamos y podemos dar
pasos de un metro treinta pasos y
entonces estamos en correos de costa
rica- 30 pasos de un metro 30 metros de
distancia
cuando hagamos los mismos 30 pasos ya no
van a ser de un metro van a ser
exponenciales y resulta que con los
mismos 30 pasos vamos a haber avanzado
mil millones de metros lo cual equivale
a haberle dado la vuelta 26 veces a la
tierra en vez de haber llegado a hacer
en frente donde está el colgador esa
tasa de cambio se da porque las
tecnologías están creciendo a esa
velocidad pero además porque se están
combinando entre sí y cuando entendemos
eso entendemos que si nos vamos a
digitalizar es la única opción de seguir
sobreviviendo versus quedarnos como
estamos en el dominio físico y que nos
atropelle la evolución si nos vamos a
digitalizar me gustaría repasar algunos
conceptos básicos con todos ustedes
primero que nada nadie dijo que fuera
fácil digitalizar se va a ser un proceso
complejo costoso frustrante en que nos
vamos a estar equivocando
permanentemente ya lo decía rebeca con
los dos ponía los ejemplos me callo de
película esa presentación porque él
sirve para ilustrar y para comprender
mejor precisamente el costo de la
experimentación vamos a entender si nos
vamos a digitalizar
no se trata de tener una app o una
página de internet eso ya lo tenemos
todos pero eso no es digitalizar si
digitalizarse es sustituir el ser humano
cuando se sustituye al ser humano se
automatiza los procesos se digitalizan
cuando se digitalizan sedes materializan
entonces vamos a hacer inversiones o
préstamos bancarios sin que intermedien
sin que participen seres humanos en ese
proceso vamos a tener que entender que
no podemos transformar nuestras empresas
si no cambiamos la cultura institucional
la cultura está hecha para el mundo
físico entonces tenemos que comenzar
desde la alta dirección desde los
directores de la junta directiva hasta
los mandos medios y los niveles más
bajos de la organización para que todos
estén listos para poder hacer el cambio
de el mundo físico al mundo digital
vamos a tener que apasionarnos por la
cultura del cliente ya eso me remito a
los últimos comentarios que hizo rebeca
que se le ve a ella la pasión que tiene
en precisamente poder y apasionarse con
entender lo que están haciendo los
clientes pero para hacer eso igual que
lo dijo ella vamos a tener que estar
experimentando y cuando experimentamos
a cometer errores cuando cometemos
errores qué es lo que pasa hoy en día en
las instituciones que nos dan con el
garrote por lo menos la práctica de la
zanahoria y el garrote tenemos que
olvidarnos del garrote y dejar solo la
zanahoria porque los procesos de
innovación hay experimentación y en los
procesos de experimentación cometemos
errores y los errores no se pueden
seguir penalizando porque entonces vamos
a penalizar la iniciativa de las
personas a hacer esas experimentaciones
y finalmente va a haber una reticencia
natural de todos los que trabajan en las
oficinas con papeles y con el dominio
físico en mundo como lo conocemos hoy
diciendo de todas las formas posibles
que la digitalización no es posible que
eso no se puede llegar a ustedes porque
la cco porque es muy caro porque las
computadoras no tienen los procesadores
porque falta mucho tiempo
todas las excusas posibles y quizás
entonces la única forma de digitalizar y
cambiar el mep sea poniendo un pequeño
mes en un garaje
y que una vez que ellos tengan los
sistemas educativos llegan los sistemas
financieros para el mundo financiero que
sean competitivos entonces que vengan y
les roben los clientes y se apoderen
como se estaría apoderando posiblemente
course era de muchos de los cursos
universitarios en el mundo
entonces si ese es el proceso y queremos
pasar de lo físico a lo digital tenemos
también que tener paciencia de entender
que el mundo físico no va a desaparecer
de la noche a la mañana va a desaparecer
más rápido lo que creemos pero no va a
desaparecer de la noche a la mañana en
esta gráfica que es una curva normal lo
que nos indica es que siempre hay en la
cola de la curva un grupo de fiebres que
son los que les gusta la tecnología son
los que hacen fila 24 horas antes de que
salga el último apple el colector para
tenerlos de primeros y no importa si
sirvió si los días agradables y los
agradables bajan todos los app
sencillamente por el gusto de tenerlos
porque son apasionados por la tecnología
pero así como hay ese grupo del otro
lado en la curva normal lo que va a ver
es los escépticos los que nunca van a
tener la tecnología van a querer seguir
yendo a la sucursal física bancaria y lo
van a hacer no porque les encante eso
necesariamente sino porque tienen
limitaciones el nivel de edad oa nivel
de educación o porque simplemente no
quisieron y vamos a ser exitosos en el
proceso
digitalización solo cuando podamos dar
ese salto de ese 16% de los fiebres
iniciales y estamos realmente
compartiendo dentro de la curva normal
dentro de la parte alta de la curva con
ese porcentaje importante de
consumidores que realmente nos van a
utilizar los servicios financieros desde
un celular porque son realmente útiles y
agradables entonces en conclusión el
mundo físico y el mundo digital van a
tener que convivir por un buen rato
vamos a tener que hacer ambas cosas a la
vez no vamos a poder escoger en el corto
plazo si hacemos una o se hacemos los
otros nos vamos a tener que
transformarnos a no ser que apartamos de
cero con un start up y lo hagamos
totalmente digital en el mundo eso ya
está pasando ese es un ecosistema de las
startups que hay en fintech en el mundo
entero está está trazada está ya tiene
un año posiblemente hoy esa lámina se
vería bastante más densa con bastantes
más empresas ese grupo de empresas están
haciendo lo que esencialmente tiene que
hacer un sistema financiero están
metiéndose en la intermediación y en los
sistemas de pagos todos esos que están
ahí
raps que se presentan o desarrollar un
mercado de préstamos donde van los
oferentes de dinero y los demandantes de
dinero y se hacen préstamos entre sí sin
la regulación de un sistema de
supervisión financiera como el que
conocemos nosotros este otro grupo
también hace préstamos pero esos
préstamos son de persona a persona y
entonces ahí no hay mercado
sencillamente uno le dice al otro sin
conocer es igual que pedimos un über y
viene mario carlos o mariah a recogernos
pues le veremos sacar los varios maría
que los preste siempre eso sí se los
pagamos la semana entrante y este otro
grupo hace todo el sistema de pagos que
hoy conocemos y le quiero decir a rebeca
que cuando haga un focus group del
simple móvil que por favor me llame yo
paso frustrados de tener que hacer un
simple móvil poniendo una coma diciendo
veces el teléfono y una coma y ese es el
número esos sistemas que están haciendo
en el mundo son ampliamente amigables
son fáciles de usar son bonitos de usar
nos dan ganas de transferir plata a los
demás entonces eso es lo que estamos
compitiendo en el mundo
y finalmente esta otra parte de la
lámina son las plataformas para hacer
inversiones y ahí hay 22 cuadros que tal
vez poniéndoles su cima no se ven la
primera son plataformas de inversión que
sustituyen a los corredores de bolsa
como nos conocemos hoy y en la parte de
abajo están los robo advisors que
sustituyen una parte aún más importante
que es en que se invierte las
recomendaciones de inversión cuando se
diseña el país y se dice va el 40 por
ciento de acciones él se siente en deuda
etcétera esa recomendación la hace un
robot que toma decisiones de compra y de
venta sin que medie un ser humano y
nosotros son otras empresas que hacen
otras partes no esenciales de las
funciones de un sistema financiero
eso es en el mundo en costa rica también
tenemos nuestras propias fintech y costa
rica al menos esas dos me llamaron la
atención y se les 15 por eso presentar
la primera que se llama la isla es un
chat con inteligencia artificial que
puede contestar preguntas que en ese
ejemplo que estaba en la pantalla las
hacen sobre sistemas de tarjetas de
crédito y entonces usted escribe y la
inteligencia artificial de un aparatito
le contesta y le dice de qué se trata o
cómo es que se tiene que hacer la
gestión la segunda es la que yo le
quiero decir cuando me entrevisté
y el sistema de pagos esto es una app
diseñado por un costarricense que tiene
la monada de que él trabaja en el sector
médico y eso lo quiero resaltar porque
las tecnologías no solamente van en una
línea de atrás
lapan de una industria a la otra
industria entonces de una tecnología que
comenzó a parís istema médico está
afectando el sistema financiero en una
forma muy competitiva muy agradable como
lo haría por ejemplo como lo hizo apple
cuando fue el que detonó en la
competencia y el líder en el mercado
telefónico yo les aseguro que ninguna
empresa telefónica cinco años antes de
apple había puesto como una amenaza a la
industria las computadoras como no creo
que algún banco haya puesto como una
amenaza competitiva el que alguien del
sector de salud venga a resolver la vida
y hacerlo más fácil que lo que lo hemos
hecho quienes estamos en el sector
financiero
dicho esto entonces como imaginamos que
será nuestro sistema financiero en los
próximos cinco años y ahí tenemos
la mente para volar todo lo que queramos
vamos a tener yo me imagino a un light
la que no digita sino que conversé común
y que le explique casi cómo lo haces ir
pero sí como pasa consiste así que le
digamos sí llámeme a fulano y lo que le
dice es el clima tiene tal temperatura
sino que realmente va a entender la voz
de entender las palabras iba a poder
contestar nos lo que le estamos
preguntando me lo imagino también con
una firma electrónica que no tenga sus
aparatos y que no haya que ir a un banco
y todas esas cosas tan complicadas si
estos aparatitos ya le lee en la cara
uno para desbloquear sé pues que le lean
el iris de lógico del iris del ojo ya
tenemos la firma digital y hay ese lado
ya lucía ya que ver cómo regula que
alguien firme con el iris del ojo vamos
a tener posiblemente un crowdfunding
sistemas de préstamos que van a ser una
participación importante del mercado
quizás un 50 por ciento podemos creer
que es mucho pero estamos en el mundo
exponencial no lineal y entonces esto va
a crecer mucho más rápido de lo que lo
podemos imaginar hoy vamos a tener al
robot vice
sustituyendo nos a todos los corredores
de bolsa y estaríamos haciendo alguna
otra cosa después del robo adviser vamos
a tener sistemas de pago que no
requieren de un topping jones y yo yo os
puedo hacer una transferencia de un
celular
sí sí puedo siempre y cuando no se me
haya olvidado llevarme el token porque
no lleva el token entonces no me deja
hacer la transferencia vamos a hacer
una unión del mundo analítico del big
data con la inteligencia artificial y
todos los economistas que están sentados
en nuestras empresas van a tener un
competidor que les va a resolver el
mundo y va a ser el trabajo de ellos hoy
en día un economista con inteligencia
artificial vale 100 mil dólares cuando
una empresa tiene cinco economistas las
cargas sociales te cuestan más que cien
mil dólares y eso ya es tecnología que
está disponible en el mercado vamos a
tener un uso abundante de cripto monedas
y si tenemos cripto monedas
esas transferencias que hagamos al
exterior le van a poner el reto al doña
rocío aguilar de cómo va a cobrar el 15
por ciento de las transferencias al
exterior si lo hicimos en cripto monedas
vamos a tener seguramente un sistema de
liquidación y compensación basado en el
block change como el que ya existe en
singapur hoy en día vamos a tener
teléfonos con sucursales electrónicas en
cada uno de nuestros teléfonos y vamos a
poner a dudar al banco nacional y al
banco de costa rica cuya ventaja
competitiva fue la cadena de
distribución de que van a hacer ellos
con 250 sucursales cada uno cuando todos
tenemos una sucursal en la bolsa de
nuestros caminos vamos a tener una
reducción muy significativa del efectivo
y medios electrónicos de pago y hacer
todo eso que estamos soñando nos va a
llevar a un gran final el gran final es
que vamos entonces a tener que cobrar
mucho menos por lo que hacemos de la
misma manera que haberse transformado la
prensa en digital les bajó las tarifas y
entonces vamos a tener que hacerlo por
volumen y si el volumen no está en costa
rica por eso se llama
porque lo hacemos con todos en el mundo
y bueno esto de estar soñando no es una
cosa nueva en 1962 ya lo habían hecho y
los jets son soñaron cómo iba a ser el
mundo dentro de 100 años inventaron
muchas de las cosas que realmente vimos
en el futuro pintaron las cámaras de
bronceado hicieron los relojes
inteligentes pensaron en que iban a
existir medios digitales hace 56 años
pensaron también imaginaron soñaron en
pantallas planas cuando los televisores
eran de este tamaño pensaron también en
que en el futuro y van a ver bandas
transportadoras en que íbamos a tener
robots es el robot inhala que limpiaba
la casa para los que se acuerden y ahora
tener robots que ya existen hoy en día
que iban a tener videojuegos y se ven la
imagen de ese niño es idéntica tanto en
la posición la postura de él como el
juguetito que tiene en frente a lo que
hoy en día nosotros tenemos en nuestras
familias en nuestras casas cuando están
jugando con eso inventaron las
videollamadas y cámara digital dijimos
que era uno de los grandes cambios en la
humanidad inventaron los vehículos que
vuelan solos y que sean personales
solo se equivocaron los jacksons en una
cosa imaginaron esto para dentro de 100
años a partir del 1962 y lo tenemos hoy
porque no vieron que el mundo cambiaba
exponencialmente y no linealmente
entonces que no nos pase lo de los
jackson es que nos veamos que el futuro
de los días entonces hoy y si nosotros
vemos que el futuro realmente llegó
porque vamos a creer que solo llegó en
los medios de comunicación en los medios
de transporte en los aparatos de vídeo
en la salud porque no va a ver afectado
también el sistema financiero y si vemos
eso entendemos entonces mejor que el
ecosistema de startups financieras ya
está ahí afuera operando y si entendemos
que hay ese ecosistema entendemos
también que todos nosotros somos un
ecosistema del sistema financiero
costarricense solo que actuamos en el
dominio físico y no en el dominio
digital lo que sigue ahora es sumarse su
über izar el sistema de transición del
sistema del dominio físico al dominio
digital es hacerlo en conjunto de una
economía colaborativa en la que todos
estemos aportando a la gran transición
el sistema financiero en la que juntos
podamos soñar cómo será el sistema
financiero después de los jets muchas
gracias